[Musique]
les gens croient tout savoir sur vous
d'après votre apparence
mais ce n'est pas aussi simple surtout
quand il s'agit de moi
avec moi c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué pardon j'ai failli tuer
[Musique]
j'avais une vie parfaite jusqu'au jour
où je te laisse tout a changé
c'est une erreur et non
quand vous le voyez vous vous dites oh
il est gros et montrer aux autres ils
vont fertiliser le prêt vous dit où ses
peurs qui êtes vous assez una mois-ci
dos et moi c'est quoi tromper ou 13 vous
vous dites lui c'est se battre je viens
sélectionnés ou tord je vais prendre
chez lui la vie pour toi je ne suis pas
un toro de combat vous pouvez m'aider à
sortir ici c'est le magnifique coin des
chevaux et là c'est le coin et écoute un
des taureaux bonne soirée et puis on
fera corps des mines a besoin de moi je
vais partir d'ici et je ne laisserai
personne derrière moi c'est un plan
génial c'est exactement comme nous
c'était pas exactement comme nous
enregistrons de fond s'attendait moins
attendu ce moment pendant toute ma vie
pour use
c
[Musique]
omagh la compagnie sonore
ma pouvoir s'enfuir par ta vu mon
derrière ont récemment
moi
il arrive il sait quelque chose
[Musique]
les jolis petits écureuils quoi
berisha
e
[Musique]